bonsoir à vous paula slayer merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
cette première marche des drapeaux c'est
un test pour le nouveau gouvernement
allemand
toutefois cette note devait prendre
place et il ya plusieurs semaines
c'est une zac la marge de la journée de
jérusalem l assemblée d'habitude
plusieurs centaines d'oliviers en
général le gel israélien
il s'agit d'une célébration de la
reprise elle du mur de lamentations en
1967 israéliens arrivent du pays entier
avec des drapeaux ou le traverse
jérusalem le problème c'est que cette
marche pelé a été souvent une
provocation
notamment parce qu'une partie de cette
marche à passe par les quartiers arabes
de jérusalem il ya cinq semaines à
quelques instants après le début de la
marche le hamas a lancé les premières
roquettes vers israël
et cela a ouvert le conflit et un terme
à la marche
cette nouvelle marche est organisée
quelques jours à peine après
l'investiture du nouveau gouvernement
une omerta libénautes week
il faudrait regarder attentivement si sa
taille marche va provoquer des heurts
et quelle sera la réaction de naphtaline
est celle qui est un promu ministre
d'extrême droite mais qui a formé une
coalition avec des partis du centre et 2
p de la gauche ont donc c'est il y à des
heures aujourd'hui il sera dans une
posture très compliqué car il ne veut
pas se poser assez sympa j'ai lectorale
et dans l'entente ne veut pas avouer qu
aller à l'encontre de ses partenaires de
coalition où ils sont très à gauche
mais la marche s'est déroulée sans
décidant donc naftali bennett n'a pas dû
prendre le choix difficiles aujourd'hui
alors une marche vous nous le dites qui
s'est déroulée sans incident et pourtant
on craignait quand même un regain de
violences notamment entre le hamas et
les forces israéliennes
c'est inquiète 8 va mieux les officiers
israéliens se trouvaient dans la vieille
ville
[Musique]
l'armée israélienne avait havre déployés
à son système de protection que l'on
appelle le dôme de fer car ils craignent
et d'une riposte du hamas et un seau
d'eau et de faire permet de protéger des
attaques de missiles depuis que sa bande
de gaza à cela il a également émis de
marche et on pensait qu'il y aurait pu
avoir des heures maintenant à jérusalem
est également un singe jordanie la
raison pour laquelle il n'y a pas
d'incident à éviter certains points les
bras gic plusieurs centaines de milliers
de manifestants se sont rendus à la
porte de damas mais à ce niveau ils ont
été arrêtés par des forces de sécurité
est redirigée vers jérusalem ouest et
dans le même temps on a empêché les
palestiniens d'israël de se rendre dans
cette zone a sera donc éviter des heurts
qui a été possible s'il y avait eu des
oppositions entre eux mais palestiniens
d'israël et les israéliens juifs et cela
aurait pu bien sûr déboucher sur des
violences supplémentaires cela il montre
à quel point la situation est tendue sur
place côté israélien au côté palestinien
pardon justement là aussi en plusieurs
factions palestiniennes qui
mais aussi dans le même temps à une
journée de colère aujourd'hui à gaza et
en cisjordanie occupée
est ce qu'il ya eu des mobilisations
côté palestinien et voire des centaines
de milliers d'haïtiens de santé dans la
jordanie ou ailleurs mais cela n'est pas
corrigé mais que cela pourrait mener à
une escalade de la situation mais cela
ne pas aggraver hamas et l'autorité
palestinienne et que c'était un
palestinien mahmoud abbas que ces deux
professions que l'organisme a recensé
aurait permis l'organisation de cette
marche car il s'agit d'un événement
annuel et pour les israéliens juifs
il s'agit d'une déclaration de
succession de jérusalem disant que cette
ville est à nous et que nous ne devrions
pas avoir à redouter de passer dans tel
ou tel quartier
donc on peut peut-être voir les prémices
d'une opposition directe entre l etat et
six magistrats elle exige israéliens
juifs mais avec une telle présence
policière avec toutes les mesures mises
en place en amont comme par exemple la
canalisation des eaux les finales israël
il n'y a pas eu d' escalade mais
jusqu'au dernier moment le redouté
qu'ils adorent qu'il y ait un taiseux
nord
foule en cisjordanie et ailleurs mais
comme je les dis la marche s'est
déroulée sans heurt sans violence sans
victimes
cela ne signifie pas pour autant qu'il
ne pourrait pas y avoir des tas de
violence à l'avenir et sur le terrain je
peux vous dire qu'il y avait beaucoup de
tension beaucoup de scolaires les juifs
d'israël était très choquant dans leurs
propos me disant c'est notre territoire
nous méritons de dupes être là et les
commerçants sur place les insulter et le
manifestant renvoyer des insultes et
tant que ce n'était pas une marche calme
et il ya beaucoup de colère des deux
côtés alors tout cela pour lier tranche
avec les scènes de liesse que l'on a vu
à tel aviv à jérusalem
juste après que la knesset à accorder
son vote de confiance au gouvernement
formé par ailleurs la pid diriger
maintenant par naftali bennett
de son côté le hamas pour le hamas
rien ne change ce gouvernement ne change
rien quels sont les espoirs d'apaisement
de ces tensions israélo-palestiniennes
maintenant c'est à dire le hamas et tous
les dirigeants calais c'est bien on dit
que les personnes pouvoir en israël ne
changeait rien prix s'ajustent benyamin
nétanyahou de naftali bennett pour eux
c'est la même chose ils sont faits du
même bois
ce sont deux dirigeants de droite est
d'ailleurs naftali bennett est même
encore plus à droite que benyamin
nétanyahou donc ils n'ont aucun espoir
que les choses changent
du côté israélien c'est ce qu'ils ont
déclaré dans des déclarations du hamas
et de l'autorité palestinienne
aussi longtemps que l'occupation
israélienne continue alors il leur
apporte peu qui est premier ministre
parti à israélien cependant et se trouve
au parlement et au gouvernement
c'est la première fois de toute
l'histoire d'israël
c'est ce qu'un parti arabe entre dans le
gouvernement donc pour certains c'est
peut être un pas dans la bonne voie et
cela pourrait peut-être contribué à
apaiser les tensions
israélo-palestiniennes mais pas en tout
cas pour les palestiniens de la bande de
gaza et de la cisjordanie
car pour eux ces oeuvres arabe où
s'alternent australiens sont des
traîtres qui ne devrait pas faire de
politique
ces scènes de liesse à tel aviv est
ailleurs dans l'opinion
traduisez la joie de certaines personnes
de voir le départ de lamine n'diaye ou
également pour certaines autres
personnes l'espoir qu'un gouvernement
avait que des partis du centre et de la
gauche puisse indiquer un changement
dans les relations entre juifs et
palestiniens mais il y a beaucoup de
travail et le gouvernement est très
divisée naftali bennet même une
coalition extrêmement hétéroclites avec
de la droite du centre et de la gauche
donc je ne dis pas que c'est impossible
mais il est un peu trop tôt pour être
optimiste quant à la suite des
événements merci beaucoup à vous paula
slayer journalistes pour rt
internationale en direct depuis à tel
aviv